didn't take long brand-new White House
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II has already been fired
lasted about ten days basically a
volatile tornado he came in he slammed
chief of swarmer chief of staff Reince
Priebus he slams the abandoned long list
of people said he'll fire everybody he
needs the fire to stop the leaks if he
needs to and he's gone scaramouche is
firing ten days after he was named to
the position via Twitter by Donald Trump
six days after he unofficially assumed
his role and 15 days before his formal
commencement in the role so his tenure
as White House communications director
was the shortest in American history he
ruined many other people's careers kind
of I mean he led - Sean Spicer resigning
although now Sean Spicer has a nice
cushy book deal so I don't know this
might are gonna work in the works for
Sean Spicer
he got Reince Priebus fired but then
partially as a result of his own doing
Reince Priebus
right Reince Priebus as replacement john
kelly comes in as the new chief of staff
and immediately recommends the firing of
anthony's scaramouche II and he also
kind of sadly Wright ruined a lot of his
own life he missed the birth of his own
child last week didn't meet his newborn
child for several days after the birth
in the midst of his wife divorcing him
who's just absolutely furious with him
for out of nowhere just pledging this
loyalty to Donald Trump his 38 year old
of wife gave giving birth to their
second child on July 24th two weeks
before the due date
while scaramouche II was in West
Virginia at that Boy Scout Jamboree with
Donald Trump he also is in the process
of trying to sell his company which by
the way has not yet been approved and
might be in question now depending on
how vengeful President Trump wants to be
although we'll talk about that in a
little bit so can we now say thanks
Trump instead of thanks Obama being
involved with Trump for Anthony scare
Meucci has been hugely damaging to his
own life and to really his family and so
many other people and there are people
who were prey
using Donald Trump for this being a
smart move what a reasonable and sober
decision made by Donald Trump Trump
didn't fire
scaramouche E because of what he did he
fired him because other people said
you've got to fire this guy I mean if we
believe that the reason was Oh his
comments about whether Steve Bannon
wants to perform oral sex on himself
those were crude comments Trump's the
grab them by the [ __ ] guy Trump has no
problem with these comments in principle
John Kelly reportedly told Trump days
ago you've got to get rid of this guy
over the weekend Trump consulted with
friends and allies and they said you've
got to get rid of them and listen you
normally don't need to check with others
to determine whether you're brand new
hire is out of line when talking to
reporters on the record about which
Trump staffers want to perform oral sex
on themselves you usually can figure out
on your own that's not that's that's
someone that is not a good idea to have
working for you what sounds like Reince
Priebus was ousted because Anthony scare
Moochie asserted himself as the Alpha ya
previous didn't really stand up for
himself and then you and John Kelly take
over the position of chief of staff and
he asserted himself as the Alpha that
Gary Moochie had to go and then you also
had Sarah Huckabee Sanders trying to
rationalize all this that was the bank
that Trump fired scare Moochie because
of his vulgar comments yeah like you
said this is the grabbing by the [ __ ]
president this is a guy who said that
Mika Brzezinski couldn't go meet with
him at mar-a-lago because she was
bleeding badly from a facebook a
facelift and that megan kelly was also
bleeding from her you know where there's
also people praising Trump's kids in all
this praising Ivanka and I don't know if
the two brothers and Jared Kushner
because they're like oh well the kids
are the voice of reason because they
said they agreed with the firing they
also said hiring scaramouche II was a
good idea
and the question I have now is will
trump kibosh the sale of Anthony
scaramouche's firm to a Chinese company
which is subject to approval here in the
United States there might be sort of
like an unspoken or maybe spoken but
maybe unspoken deal where scaramouche II
won't take anybody down with him because
you know scaramouche II has the dirt to
take down a lot of people in the Trump
administration
Trump won't block the sale of his
company but they don't be leaking though
which I guess he's against of course
yeah they're everybody's against leaking
and scaramouche II would have fired
everyone over leaking until now he's
fired
the reality is scaramouche II was a
pretty accurate representation of Trump
in both style and substance this big
scandal over how scaramouche II was
comporting himself talking about Steve
ban and performing oral sex on himself
is pretty similar to Trump talking about
grabbin by the [ __ ] its class it's
crass clueless and volatile and it turns
out that when you actually have someone
representing the real tone and tenor of
your White House accurately it's not
good for the White House this is someone
representing Trump really well and it
was embarrassing for Trump unfortunately
and now this is the third communications
director to go you have Sean Spicer out
you have dub key out and now Anthony
scaramouche II I mean you could have
prevented this whole long list of recent
firings too when you talk about Spicer
and you talk about previous sir I just
not hiring stare emoji in the first
place I mean this whole embarrassment
string wouldn't have happened I was
joking the other day maybe it was last
week or earlier this week I said hey
Trump's finally draining the swamp by
getting rid of the people that he
himself hired it was a total joke right
I've now seen that said non-city Raqqah
there are trumpets now arguing for real
I got a few emails from them a few
tweets from them saying hey why are
people criticizing Trump for all these
firings he's draining the swamp this is
what he said he would do Trump is firing
people he hired when he talked about
draining the swamp but didn't mean
getting rid of the people that were huge
hiring mistakes during the first six
months of his presidency
I thought Trump knew the best people he
was going to be hiring the real stand-up
people for his administration apparently
not right even people who didn't support
Trump or did so reluctantly said that he
would get the best people to work around
it if nothing else he would get a good
team and it's also funny how we had a
poll on david pakman.com asking who the
next Trump official was going to be to
leave yeah ie resigning or being fired
and that's pretty null at this point
because two of those options are already
gone yeah half of our half of the people
listed in our poll have already been
fired or forced to resign so we had to
take that poll down
because it was almost instantly outdated
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership